شركه متى صاحبه التطبيقات الاشهر والمردود
المادي الاعلن او الاعلى اعلنت عن تطبيق
جديد بيشبه تويتر وقالت انه هذا ردا على
تويتر التطبيق عرضه كبير مسؤوليه المنتجات
في الشركه على الموظفين واسمه داخليا في
الشركه
وفي حال ابصر النور راح يكون اسمه
واللي بيشوف صوره تطبيق حيظن انه تويتر
رسمي يعني شوفوا الالوان شوفوا مثلا اللي
او تشوفوا التصميم مثل ما شايفين تماما
مثل تويتر والتطبيق مو محتاج لانشاء حساب
جديد ولا بيانات جديده ولا شيء لانه مرتبط
بانستقرام فاي مستخدم يقدر يعني يدخل اسمه
كمستخدم وباسورد انستغرامه ويصير عنده
حساب ويدخل على التطبيق ويصير جاهز بين
يده للاستخدام ومن بين الاخبار اللي تم
تداولها عن التطبيق الجديد انه بتتم
مناقشه فكره جد كثير المشاهير اللي بدوروا
على تطبيق سهل الاستخدام وبيتصل بالامان
والمصداقيه علشان يشتركوا في التطبيق ومن
بينهم الاعلاميه والمحاوره الشهيره او
براون فري والدلاله طيب اما بالنسبه
لتاريخ طرح التطبيق فقالت متى انه عمليات
البرمجه بدات في يناير وانه راح تطرحوا
باسرع وقت ممكن للامانه طبعا هذه مو اول
مره بنشوف محاوله لاستنساخ تويتر يعني
عندنا تروت سوشيال مثلا من قبل نحاول وعمل
نفس الشيء ما حقق يعني نفس النجاح
المحققوته تويتر او عدد المستخدمين لكن
خلينا نشوف عاد ترد لما ينزل ايش راح يعمل
يمكن تكون حظوظه مختلفه خصوصا انه مدعوم
من شركه كبيره مثل متى يعني
[موسيقى]